this is a production of Cornell
University it's good thank you Leah for
the introduction and thank you all for
having me today I'm really excited to be
here and get to talk about some of my
own research obviously I do human
dimensions of Agriculture I actually
started as an environmental scientist in
my undergrad and then it got kind of
pulled into the social science side
because I realized I was really
interested in why people were doing what
they were doing related to the
environment and that kind of developed
into why people are doing what they're
doing in agriculture specifically and so
that's really what this presentation is
going to be about and integrating that
social science perspective into
agricultural research so I'm going to
talk about pesticide resistance social
collapse and strategies for Community
Management approaches and this grew out
of um my dissertation research that I
still continue today working with a lot
of weed scientists so I'll introduce you
a little bit to pesticide resistance I'm
sure a lot of you know what this is when
I give this talk to sociologist this is
a bit of a longer slide but so the
inherited ability of a pest to survive
and reproduce following exposure to a
dose of pesticides that's normally
lethal I'm sure a lot of us are familiar
with this
issue and that issue has been growing
especially with use of glyphosate so
this was estimated agricultural use for
glyphosate in 1995 with the darker areas
being more use per square mile and this
is the estimated use in 2019 and so
basically if you use one herbicide over
and over and over and over again the
plant is going to evolve resistance to
that herbicide and suddenly you are
spray spraying round up and you can't
actually kill anything so this has been
a trend that continues to today so this
is the number of glyphosate resistant
species starting in about 1996 and going
up through 2020 so you can see there's
been a massive increase in the number of
weed species that are resistant to
glyphosate and so one of the common
answers is well okay so it's resistant
to glyphosate we just use another
herbicide right issue with that is you
get multiple resistances things can be
resistant to more than just one chemical
and so we see this increase specifically
in Weeds resistant to two three four
more kinds of herbicides so it's not
really an issue that can just be solved
by chemical management and this is
really what the weed scientists I was
working with were discovering back
during my dissertation is they had tried
to say hey we know that integrated weed
management works and rotating chemicals
works but nobody's actually doing it so
maybe it's more than just a weed science
problem maybe it's more than just a
chemistry problem so some of the reasons
why resistance is an issue higher weed
management costs uh for instance Palmer
amaranth that's herbicide resistant in
cotton in Georgia was shown to increase
management cost on the farm by 58% so
this is a really big concern for Farmers
economically lot of motivation to deal
with that also lower crop yields can be
a problem increased tillage is one
that's come up recently where maybe
you're going back to tillage to control
your weeds and that's a big problem for
soil conservation when I was out at
University of Idaho uh in the Pacific
Northwest doing some of this work this
was a really big deal lots of Highly
erodable land out there and a lot of
soil conservation efforts so the
increase tillage was a big issue there's
also potentially a return to more
volatile herbicides so if glyphosate
isn't working maybe we go back to some
old chemistries and some chemistries
have actually been released by the EPA
that were previously not allowed and now
people in Georgia can actually use those
um and I've also been in focus groups
where people tell me some of the
herbicides they're using and and the
weed scientists who are with me are like
that's that's illegal I'm like okay wow
they are really uh using whatever it is
they have at hand another problem that
comes up is societal unrest because
obviously if you're having this problem
and farmers are already already under a
lot of stress just trying to survive
then this is going to put you in
competition with other farmers and
there's all sorts of kind of community
issues that I'll get into in a little
bit and specifically the murder of
farmer Mike Wallace in Arkansas which I
will go into specifically and that was a
result of daa drift so we see a lot of
kind of community collapse around this
issue as well so there's a variety of
ways that weed scientists say we should
address herbicide resistance and so this
is from a seminal article by Jason
Norsworthy um who are worked with and he
lists all of these various best
management practices for dealing with
herbicide resistance and so I'm just
going to go through these really quick
but it's things like understanding the
biology of the weed using a diversified
approach maintaining Weed Free Fields
Plant weed crop seed Scout Fields
multiple modes of action labeled
herbicide rates cultural management
integrated and biological management
prevention of weed seed movement and
management of weed seeds at Harvest and
then finally management of field borders
so they have all these best management
practices and they come to the
sociologist and say why aren't they
doing
this and I'm like
wow that is a lot right there right that
is a lot to expect Farmers to do all at
once and they say we're doing but we
know that if they do this they will
manage it they'll have these economic
benefits it'll have these social
benefits and we've been going out there
we've been doing this Outreach and
people aren't doing it and they really
wanted us to go out and find out why
aren't Farmers listening to us and that
actually wasn't the message that we got
so I was hired to do some research on
this and I'm going to talk about my
research spanning from my dissertation
work which is in from like 2014 to 2017
and then I'll actually talk about a bit
of my work out at Washington State and
at Iowa State University but in general
my research methodology spans
qualitative and quantitative research
the qualitative part I've done focus
groups interviews Community meetings
listening sessions content analysis
pretty much everything that you can
think of in qualitative work and that
was mostly to say what even is the issue
we don't know how farmers are thinking
about this so first let's go out and ask
them and do some exploratory work and
then I've also done some quantitative
work primarily surveys testing the kind
of themes that I found from the
qualitative research and so what I was
doing for my first project was really
trying to understand just the social
context of herbicide resistance and what
I was getting to was that farmers
absolutely knew what herbicide
resistance was they understood it they
understood how it happened that was not
a mystery to them right and these weed
scientists were just like they're just
not educated enough I'm like no they
definitely are like they know what's
going on here and furthermore they want
to do it pretty much all the farmers I
talked to are like ideally yes I would
be doing integrated weed management but
there are things that are stopping me
from achieving that and there were
things like the size of the farm the
structure of the farm economies of scale
really all of these structural barriers
that farmers had that they were like I
can't go out and Scout my field for
weeds every single day and handh them my
farm is too big and it has to be that
big for me to survive as a farmer there
are also various kind of ideologies that
people held around this and so as ass I
olist that's more of what I focused on
so I'm going to introduce you to two of
those today and the first one was this
techno optimism that farmers had and the
second was individualism so these were
really kind of ways that farmers saw the
world that were preventing them from
using more integrated practices so
techno optimism was essentially the
belief that a new Miracle herbicide was
going to be developed and come out and
kind of save everything where we don't
have to worry about herbicide resistance
because the next one's going to come
we're going to get the next glyphosate
we're going to get the next Roundup and
then we won't have to worry about it and
then that's going to happen again after
that other one and then again after that
other one and this has kind of happened
in the past which is part of why they
believe this but a new herbicide mode of
action hasn't come out in like 3040
years something like that so it's not
happening quickly and then individualism
is basically this belief in the sanctity
of autonomy and agency for very
individualistic culture in the US and
farmers in particular are very much like
I make my decision on my farm and nobody
else can tell me how to do that and then
therefore I cannot tell my neighbor how
to farm either this is a problem when
you have weeds that are moving between
people's Farms when you have resistant
insects that are moving between people's
Farms you have to collaborate in order
to manage a landscape scale issue
effectively but farmers are really stuck
in that I manage my land and nobody else
does so I'll give you a couple examples
of quotes from my focus groups and
meetings so techno optimism I had people
saying I think we're all hoping probably
there's somewhere in that chemistry
there's something that comes around
that's a new version stall long enough
maybe the figure something out give us
another product that's about it so when
I asked how do you solve herbicide
resistance this was the answer also had
you can't tell me that it can't be done
you can't tell me that there ain't a
chemical out there to kill that weed I
will never believe
it and in other words trying to keep a
company keeping new products moving in
the pipeline because that's what's going
to have to happen eventually is this is
never going to go away you're always
going to have an issue with whatever
herbicide comes out and I was like yes
you're on the right track and then so
keeping new options coming is more
important than really the agricultural
practices and all
that then Roundup definitely allowed
people to get bigger because it worked
so good for so long that you could
double your Acres easily and get the
work done but I don't see the cultivator
coming back and then everyone laughed I
think we're going to have to find
chemicals so we're not going to till the
Farm's too big we have to find chemicals
and then the Silver Bullet talk came up
a lot we get a silver bullet and
everyone loads their gun up with the
silver bullet and just empties It Well
by then everything starts getting
resistant to it we've got to find
another bullet well now we're looking
for gold bullets not silver
bullets so there is a lot of this
rhetoric right around the hope for a new
Silver Bullet the new thing that is
going to save us so that we don't have
to deal with these more complex
management practices and the weed
scientists I was working with were very
familiar with this idea and we're like
yes we're absolutely hearing that but
they were like why are farmers hoping
for this we keep telling them it's not
coming and really interestingly I think
a lot of it had to do with fear I think
a lot of farmers knew that this option
is not coming but they also felt like
they had no other choice so in response
to this first quote here another grower
said that's the hope I would say that
might be all it is is Hope and this
really spoke to me because I think that
the Techno optimism they were
experiencing
wasn't necessarily I actually believe
this is going to happen it was I don't
see any other option I don't see any
other way out of this
situation so it was really this kind of
fear that was driving techno optimism it
was a fatalistic attitude it was a loss
of a sense of agency that was like I
cannot manage this my farm is too big I
can't talk to my neighbors about it like
what am I I I can't manage it by myself
so I have to rely on a herbicide so that
was driven by this lack of agency Farm
size and really seeing limited options
for how they could manage
weeds and really interestingly in my
survey research I did some statistical
analysis and modeling and we saw that
people who had more of this techno
optimistic belief relied more strongly
on a herbicide based weed management
strategy they were less likely to go
with integrated weed management and more
likely to go very herbicide
heavy but really this wasn't really an
unquestioned faith based on lack of
knowledge that's what a lot of the weed
SCI thought it was but I don't think
that's what was going on here they
really had a knowledge of their own
powerlessness in this situation and that
was driving these feelings of dependency
and these feelings of techno optimism
that this new herbicide has to come out
and save
us
so moving on to individualism these are
very tied together as we'll soon see but
a couple quotes So techno optimism was
one big theme that came out
individualism was another we had this
great conversation in one of the groups
where the first participant said' bite
your tongue I said huh said bite your
tongue and wait harder yeah till it
bleeds so this was me asking what would
happen if your neighbor had herbicide
resistance Weeds on their farm and this
is what they said they are not talking
to each other about
this another answer was my answer would
be nothing I don't see myself going up
and knocking on the door and saying you
need to get rid of your weeds and I
think that's probably going to be a
typical answer economics have to run the
show and then I had some neighbors come
up to me concerned about another
neighbor in our area that has issues
with spraying but I mean nobody did
anything about it but they're
concerned and if it's at the back end
maybe if it was a few plants you could
go out there and pull them by hand if
they don't fire at you from the house or
[Music]
something so really not a situation in
which they felt they could go and talk
to their neighbors about this they did
say if their neighbor came to them and
asked for advice they would be more than
happy to give it advice but there is
this culture of you cannot go and tell
your neighbor what to do even if that's
going to come over and affect you and
it's going to get onto your farm they
said it'd be like telling your neighbor
what color to paint their truck you know
they had those kind of quotes and for a
long time I didn't really understand
this but I also had an experience where
I was living in Idaho and I was breaking
leaves and I hate breaking leaves and
it's taking forever and my neighbors
across the street are not raking their
leaves and they have a ton of leaves and
they're blowing across the street into
my yard and I'm really pissed off and
it's taking me a bunch of time and I'm
not going over there and being like hey
you need to break your leaves like
that's part of the culture in the US is
it's very indiv individualistic and it
was hard for them to have these
confrontations but there was also kind
of a desire to do it in some ways where
one grower said I do ask a lot of my
friends what did you use what did you
use and then compare it to what I'm
doing and it would be nice to have a
bigger Bank of that knowledge so at the
same time that techno optimism people
were starting to kind of doubt it and
look for other options individualism and
much the same way not everyone was super
on board with they maybe wanted that
larger Suite of information and wanted
to be having more
conversations so for individualism also
in my survey I looked at what lowered
individualism what made people more
likely to collaborate and one thing was
How concerned they were about pesticide
resistance was this a big issue for them
another was the actual presence of the
weeds in their own
Fields so having the weed in your own
field makes you more likely to want to
collaborate with other people dealing
with the same issue the visibility of
the issue and having direct experience
was very important and this was really
interesting because high levels of
concern low levels of individualism led
to more communication and collaboration
with more neighbors and that was
statistically significant in predicting
more integrated weed management
practices so when they were moving away
from this individualism when they were
communicating and collaborating with
their neighbors they saw integrated weed
management as more feasible they're more
likely to use that and less likely to
rely on Technologies and just on
herbicides so we are wondering if this
is a possible path to integrated Pest
Management if we can direct this concern
less into like a fatalism that leads to
techno optimism and more into hey you
can work together to try and solve some
of this
problem now unfortunately we have seen
potentially more Community collapse than
we have seen
collaboration so I have another quote
here from one of my focus groups in Iowa
this was conducted in Spring of
2016 this was said in a joking manner
but fairly serious topic where I asked
what would you do if your neighbor had
herbicide resistance issues and somebody
said just think shoot the neighbor
everyone laughed hoping he'll die hoping
he'll die soon oh yeah and everyone was
like cracking up like you know very much
a
joke but they were really getting to
that point of like you cannot talk to
your neighbor and then a couple months
later in Arkansas in October of 2016
Mike Wallace was murdered in a dampa
drift
dispute so the things that my farmers
were talking about were very serious and
had very serious consequences in this
other context so daa was like the new
herbicide right it got deregulated it
got reformulated you had D resistance
soybeans and it was like it's not going
to drift as much this is going to help
and people were using it off label using
it before it was approved and it drifted
into this guy's field killed a bunch of
his soybeans and there was a murder over
this so we've seen a lot of social
collapse and it's like okay techno
optimism the next technology the next
fix damba has actually furthered
conflict and furthered extreme
individualism where you're looking out
for yourself and you're not
collaborating with your neighbors on
this issue and it's pushed producers
kind of away from Community Management
it's pitting people against each other
in terms of I'm taking care of my own
crop and you need to take care of your
own crop you need to plant dber
resistant
soybeans and some producers are becoming
really disenchanted with this next
technology and if you see interviews in
Arkansas around this time like this was
very impactful for people right this was
very impactful and people saying we need
to do something we need to change this
culture is not working
anymore and so I had an Arkansas focus
group farmer this was in 2016 before the
murders but he was kind of doubting this
Silver Bullet he said well they're not
called the Silver Bullet but anyway the
next option we have you can tell
nobody's happy with it it's nothing to
be happy about we're all more or less
wondering how bad it's going to be not
how good it's going to be so people were
doubting the Silver Bullet they were
doubting the Techno optimism they were
starting to see problems with this very
individualistic kind of society approach
and we are wondering is this an
opportunity so a lot of times opportuni
is in sociology we see as points of
disintegration as points where things
are falling apart right something the
the pan is in the fire it's like the
fire is on your doorstep you have to do
something so maybe some of this is a way
to have an entry point into having
discussions and so what our team has
proposed is using Community as a way
forward and this has also happened in
Aransas Arkansas is the center of a lot
of these discussions because it has a
lot of herbicide resistance problems but
Arkansas actually initiated their own
Community Management program for
herbicide resistant Palmer amaran it was
called the zero tolerance program it was
voluntary there was an extension
educator who was involved and a bunch of
farmers who all got together and would
say we are not going to tolerate a
single polymer amaranth in our fields
and they put up signs being like we're
part of this program and they reduced
their weed seed bank from 2010 to 2012
significantly so this really worked
getting people together and it was
almost like a peer pressure thing in
some ways but it was also a support
group in some ways for these farmers of
sharing the strategies that worked for
them there was a story of one farmer who
was like dressed in his Sunday Best
going to church with his family he was
driving along and saw a pigweed in
somebody else's field but they were part
of this program and he knew them and he
was like I'm getting that thing and he
got out of his truck and climbed through
the ditch in his Sunday Best and pulled
out that pig weed right so there was
kind of this community support aspect
and we're all in this together there was
making people feel a lot more empowered
and really having positive outcomes in
terms of integrated weed management and
managing resistance the problem is
eventually the extension guy retired and
the program fell apart this is a trend
that you will see again and
again so I did some work in Washington
state with this and we can talk about
that later if it's of interest but right
now my focus is on the Iowa Pest
resistence Management program which was
started before I got to Iowa state but I
have been involved in it and it was
essentially started after a Statewide
meeting in 2015 where people are like we
really need to address pesticide
resistance and we need to do it
collectively we need to do it as a
community we can't just just let Farmers
try and go It Alone we need support
systems here and so as a community-
based Grassroots approach to getting
Pest Management res issues resolved in
Iowa and we have four pilot communities
in Harrison County Story County
Northeast Iowa and Northwest Iowa two of
those are focused on herbicide
resistance and then we also have one on
soybean aphid and one on corn rootworm
and those were kind of our challenge
communities of like the issue isn't
quite as big in those communities yet so
we're like can we get ahead of it can we
get people to act proactively the answer
more or less was no but we gave it a
shot right so some of the stuff that has
come out of the Iowa pest resistance
Management program include us developing
and refining a model for Community
change so basically understanding the
context of the community that you're in
doing more of a participatory framework
and understanding how that Community
works and what kind of resources they
have and how communities themselves can
understand that and use that
understanding to better manage their own
resources econ team also developed and
is currently refining an economic
analysis tool which is kind of hard to
see here but basically they worked with
one of our groups and got these
baselines for what are you know the
costs for your inputs every year how
much do you spend on this how much do
you spend on that what are your costs
for managing weeds and then they had
different types of uh management you
could do like Band-Aids which are small
fixes or big structural changes like
crop rotations and then they forecasted
out how much money that would save you
so that's one of the tools that we are
current Curr ly working on developing
further and then we also have been
working with nrcs to do conservation
enhancement programs so our Statewide
nrcs office has actually done this
really cool uh integrated Pest
Management conservation enhancement
where you go through and check off all
of these things that you've done and
some of them are social things it's like
going to community meetings going to
extension meetings and those can get you
points towards getting these payments
for conservation enhancement so that's
something that we're really interested
in as well but part of the issue with
this group and these four pilot
communities has also been that a lot of
them have kind of stagnated so I came in
halfway through a project on this and I
was on a grant and I be I became the pi
for the grant because the other one had
retired and the purpose of the grant was
let's understand why these communities
have been so successful and I got there
and I was like I don't know if they have
um so I was like I think maybe we need
to change the direction of this grant
question because I can't really explain
why they've been successful because I
don't think that they really have like
some of them really started strong and
did a lot of really good stuff but then
they kind of lost momentum right just
kind of like the the Arkansas group did
a lot of really great stuff but then
just kind of petered out so like what's
going on here what's happening here and
so my research question became why are
these communities stalling out why are
they not working what are the factors
here that are limiting people because
people were really passionate about this
it wasn't that there wasn't an issue it
wasn't that there wasn't passion so
what's going on here that's not enabling
this so I ended up doing a series of
focus groups that were why didn't this
work and so I went into the communities
and said why haven't why hasn't this
group grown why has it stalled out why
did this group not form in the first
place even though there was a lot of
excitement about managing pesticide
resistance as a community we never
really got that off the ground what
happened so I've started coding those
focus groups and basically we found
three primary themes around why these
Focus or why these Community initiatives
have kind of Fallen apart in various
ways one of them is low investment from
Farmers and that's not necessarily in
the issue itself but farmers are really
busy right I'll get into an example of
that in a minute a second was limited
willingness to accept alternative
perspectives so sometimes these groups
got really insular and it was just like
it's what we want to do and you don't
grow by doing that and then another was
just weak horizontal networks between
farmers so there wasn't a lot of farmer
collaboration in general and so it was
really hard to collaborate on this
specific issue so I'll give some
examples of this so low investment from
Farmers we had a farmer here saying that
there's a lot of absentee people so
they're referring to land owners
specifically so low investment of land
owners and then the younger generation I
think is more proactive on issues like
this but there's relatively few of them
in agriculture and that quote spoke to
an issue that a lot of farmers brought
up which was that there aren't that many
of us right like how can we collaborate
when we have these massive farms and we
live so far away from each other and the
land owners aren't even here so that was
a big issue
and then also leadership was a big issue
so in one Community we had a great
leader but in this community the guy who
would kind of be the obvious leader told
us this he said I don't want to be the
leader of any group I'll follow but I
don't want to be the leader and it was
okay is that more of a wait and see kind
of approach he said absolutely I mean
I'll help I'll throw out a field day
I'll call people but a lot of people
don't want to be the chief and would
rather be let so farmers have a lot on
their plate this guy was involved in all
sorts of stuff it was really hard to
even get an interview with him because
he was so busy and so he didn't want to
be the leader there just wasn't that
level of
investment as far as limited willingness
to accept Alternatives this popped up
specifically in one of our groups where
there was a really strong leader in the
group like he really pushed that group
forward and got a lot of stuff done but
they had this to say about him so this
is a pseudonym so his name isn't
actually bill but they said people like
Bill and people dislike Bill and he has
an equal amount of enemies as he does
friends or probably more but a big big
reason Reon why we got so much
accomplished is his leadership but
that's also what's holding us back then
he said the same thing again he's a
polarizing figure you know and he has
opinions so they got this good Core
group together with this guy as the
leader but then nobody else came in and
it was bills way or the highway
right and so this guy said it's hard to
change what we're doing with the same
people in my opinion so they'd have the
same group of like 10 people for several
years and they just couldn't get any
anyone else involved and this person who
is really key to the movement didn't
want to get anyone else involved he
wanted to do things his way and to do an
effective Community Management program
you have to have a variety of opinions
and a more kind of equal governance
structure and then weak horizontal
networks this was fascinating to me uh
as a social scientist in
particular but people said things I
asked them you know what was the impact
of coid uh that made the group in part
fall apart and this person basically
said
we lack interpersonal connection now we
meet on Zoom but we don't get that
connection we don't get that Bond and
they said the people that show up in
person are the ones that are interested
in something and between them you know
they kind of form a bond and so this was
really talking about that bonding
between Growers that's maybe not
happening as much especially in this
more digital age and then we also had
again somebody saying the number of
farmers has just dwindled and farming
used to be a community and now they
don't necessarily want to come to a
meeting where they're going to see the
500 acre farmer and they just rented a
farm out from underneath that 500 acre
farmer so a lot of this individualism
and competition among Farmers but
another really interesting thing that
came up with this was farmers were
telling me we don't have a coffee shop
to meet at anymore we don't have as many
farmers in our community not as many
people are going to church so is
actually in some ways a rural
development issue of these shrinking
rural communities that did not have the
venues to create Community if you don't
have Community it's going to be really
hard to manage a resource as a
community so some of my takeaways from
this entire presentation Farmers
resistance management practices are
limited by a couple things they're
limited by techno optimism and
individualism and those are enacted in
complex ways and there's some indicators
of fatalism and disenchantment with that
techno optimism and individualism where
people are starting to see some real
holes in these theories and feeling that
like maybe I don't really believe this
maybe I'm being forced to believe this
and I would really like to manage my
weeds in a different way and maybe this
is an opportunity for change if people
are feeling this way so I would propose
community- based management as a
potential way to address these issues of
techno optimism fatalism and
individualism and give people a
community of support give them back some
agency and show them alternative
practical ways to manage weeds but this
also appears to be challenged by things
like low investment limited acceptance
of alternative Alternatives and
horizontal
networks so what might we do about that
that's kind of the position I'm in right
now right I've gotten this far where do
we go next so I have a couple
suggestions for ways forward one of
those is transdisciplinary collaboration
this is where a lot of this started is
with weed scientists reaching out to
some social scientists and helping us
understand the complex nature of this
issue in more depth so I'm currently
working with a team on an N NSF grant
that is looking to BAS basically model
Community capacity for management but
also look at is the pest actually a
landscape scale pest is it something we
should be managing at the community
level and how do those two things
intersect to see if the community
actually has potential for managing this
specific pest so I think we need more
collaboration among disciplines but also
more collaboration like with farmers and
with crop advisors and with all these
other actors who are playing a role in
this
problem polycentric governance another
big issue so that basically means that
you allow the community to self-govern
but you also have support from entities
at a national state and local level so a
lot of communities would be very
frustrated that like the EPA had blanket
regulations across the us and that they
weren't really relevant to local
realities or same thing with nrcs so
there has to be some kind of contextual
local uh involvement in
government and then also I think rural
development is going to be really
important so if we want Community
collaboration we want and we say like
okay we're see seeing these issues
Community could help this we need to
develop those communities we need to
build stronger communities and more
connected communities so it becomes an
issue not just of Agriculture but also
of rural
development so if you're particularly
interested in that feel free to shoot me
an email I'm always happy to talk about
these kinds of things and I have a
variety of articles on this subject as
well so I have just a selection of those
here that you might be able to look into
if some of these topics pequ your
interest and you want to learn more in
depth I would be happy to take questions
at this point thank you
everyone have you found any difference
between organic farmers and Farmers that
use pesticides between the like if
there's a weed and an organic farm I
assume it's not that big of a deal but
the neighbor might yeah so the question
was about differences between organic
Growers and people who are not organic
and so most of my knowledge from this
comes from a couple focus groups I did
in Iowa um in my national survey I don't
think we had like any respondents who
are really organic but in the focus
groups I had two focus groups that had
one organic grower each and this was
really really interesting because in one
of the focus groups it was like one of
the worst focus groups I've ever done in
my entire life it was like pulling teeth
I got into there and one of the guys was
like you're organic huh the other guy
was like
yeah they basically didn't talk for the
rest of the time it was just like me
being like please talk please talk they
just like hated each other um because
the organic guy saw the other guy using
p Ides as like killing his crops and
like the problem and then the
conventional guy was like well you're
the problem because you're letting weeds
come on to the farm right and then
they're spreading to my farm and it was
just really this headbutting kind of
thing but in the other focus group I did
with an organic grower right off the bat
the organic grower got ahead of it by
being like I want organic for the price
premium and then everyone
understood and so they're much more
willing to have that face-to-face
conversation of oh I understand where
you're coming from now but there's
definitely kind of more acceptance on
Organic Farms of the presence of weeds
right there's a different standard of
Good Farming and what it means to be a
good farmer but it also takes a lot of
like cognitive work to get to that point
because there's such a perception that a
good Farm is a clean farm and it's
really hard for people to move away from
away from that so for organic Growers
maybe a little easier to get to that
point of it's okay to have some weeds
but for conventional Growers it has to
be clean and that means a lot of
herbicides and that can actually result
in more resistance do you think that so
I imagine a lot of these farmers are
used to getting information on weed
management from companies that are
making products do you think that uh the
Techno optimism is that message is
coming from the companies do you think
that's a big obstacle yes long in the
short of it but it's also complex and
changing um so initially like Monsanto
when they released Roundup they
literally wrote a paper that said it
will never become
resistant like they wrote that paper and
they put that out there and I had
Growers telling me I read that paper and
I trusted it and they were really pissed
right so there was that real like techno
optimistic narrative from companies and
companies are invested in being able to
say we will give you the next solution
right but some of the content analysis
that I've done and this isn't published
for a variety of reasons but basically I
looked at websites for the made
agrochemical companies and looked at
them like 10 years back into the to the
present and how they talked about
herbicide resistance and I saw a real
transition in a lot of these companies
from being like herbicides herbicides
rotate your herbicides to suddenly
companies have a lot more pages on
integrated weed management and they have
a lot more suggestions of how you can
maintain the efficacy of their chemical
right so there has been kind of this
shift in company rhetoric towards more
integrated manag man agement and there's
also division within companies so I work
with a lot of people at agral companies
who are in like research and development
they have a very different perspective
than the people in marketing right so
it's not as simple as just saying the
companies want this there's a lot of
tension within the companies as far as
what they're talking about as
well yeah over here this is hits home
for me because I'm from Iowa oh yeah
also harison County oh my gosh also grew
up on a family farm but we rent that
farm out this is like way too arguably
too close to home but um I want to know
what the average age of the farmers that
you talk with in focus groups and then
why you
think likely because it's older the
younger generation this is me right we
are going into agriculture but not going
back onto generational Farms we're not
going into farming yeah and do you think
that impacts
or skew the age to older Farmers because
the new
generation below them don't want to farm
any
want yeah I could see that being an
issue there was a lot of concern about
Farm succession and who was going to get
the farm at some point and were they
going to pass it down to somebody or did
they even have somebody to pass it down
to right and that was very concerning
very emotional for a lot of people as
far as like I'm taking care of this land
and I want to pass it on but none of my
kids want to um that kind of a thing
there were a lot of older people who
talked in the focus groups but most of
the focus groups I did um were actually
intergenerational which is really
interesting where it would often be a
father and son who came to the focus
group together and it was really
interesting to see the difference in
perspective among the generations
because on the one hand you had the
younger people who were like maybe more
willing to innovate in some ways and
more willing to take risks but at the
same time they grew up in a world where
all you used was
glyphosate right the older guys in the
focus groups did not they remember a
time when you did other things they REM
remembered a time where it it's more
integrated and they were like if I had
to I could go get the cultivator out of
the barn and I could manage this and I
don't know that my son would know how to
do that so it was really interesting in
terms of like the younger people maybe
being more risk-taking and more
Innovative but also just not having that
experiential familiarity with doing
anything other than just straight
glyphosate for weed management yeah did
you find great talk by the way um did
you
find there was a
certain openness or interest in
incentivizing adoption of these
techniques and more importantly was in
in your experience have you found it to
actually be impactful uh as far as like
monetary incentives in terms of monetary
incentive tax incentive basically things
that affect the bottom line because
often times a major barrier and
Norsworthy talks about this in his paper
is literally the focus on short-term
economic restraints and benefits compar
longterm Necessities yeah and so part of
what I found is like people tell me
that's the issue a lot of the time I
don't know if it's actually the issue
it's definitely part of it but for
instance with our economic analysis our
team spent like literally years working
with this community to make this
economic analysis and forecasting tool
that was focused on getting them from
thinking short-term to long-term and
showing the long-term impacts of
different weed management decisions and
the team worked really hard on
developing this thing The Growers re
work said they really wanted it this was
the tool they needed we finally got
there we developed it we released it
nobody is using it nobody is using it so
I think there's definitely a strong
economics part here as far as like
incentives and what people will do but
there's something else going on right
it's not just about the money it's all
also about how much time do I spend on
the farm and do I get to go fishing on
the weekends it's also about like soil
quality it's ALS it's about all these
different things it's about ideologies
and individualism and I think to just
say that it's an economic problem yeah a
lot of people say that but then when I
dig deeper there's other things going on
which is really interesting to me but
there is definitely um a movement to do
more monetary incentives for effectively
managing pest resistance and that's one
of the things we're pursuing with nrcs
as far as like a conservation
enhancement but one of my questions is
also do incentives actually change
people's minds because there's some
research out there that indicates that
they do the conservation practice while
you're paying them but as soon as the
payments stop the conservation practice
stops so it's not changing that
underlying world view right it's not
changing their thought process about why
they do conservation so yeah complicated
relationship to incentives for sure yeah
mentioned your survey instrument on the
ideology yeah is that difficult develop
the Techno
Optimus well so we developed the survey
directly out of the focus groups so a
lot of what I was doing was like taking
statements basically from Growers and
then measuring grower agreement with
those statements from the focus group so
that's part of how I designed that and
then some of the ideology individualism
stuff I also looked at other surveys
that had done similar things in the past
Yeah question yeah you might you might
oh yeah sorry I presume we can hear ly
if she asks her question can I H she's
yeah can you hear me yes wonderful okay
great thank you so much love loved your
presentation looking forward to meeting
with you later today uh I have a
question about techno optimism and
actually novel technology because I'm
really heavily involved in looking at
electrical weeding um targeted Vision
guided spring Vision cultivation robotic
technology and I guess um if if you're
exploring this area and if if if if your
research is delving into that and if
there is a sense of optimism associated
with you know kind of you know the
coming of robots and you know uh digital
egg and artificial intelligence or if
there's again some sort of hesitation
whereas they have techno optimism for
the chemistry but you know are are not
as
optimistic or maybe are realistic about
the current status of Technology maybe
optimistic for the future just I really
am very interested in in what you think
about that absolutely great question so
it was a lot of techno optimism towards
herbicides one of the things that me and
my team were really interested in is
could we use the language and the
ideology of techno optimism in our favor
to promote more integrated weed
management practices to promote
biological or mechanical weed management
practices as the next new technology is
not a herbicide it's it's something else
right or but also making sure to not be
like it's one thing so maybe the next
techn technological innovation is a
suite of technological practices as
opposed to one technological practice I
think that's a really powerful way to
frame it because the issue with
ideologies like this is you can't just
change them right you can't just go in
and be like you should not be you know
have hope in technology anymore that's
not going to work you know that's never
going to work these are deep-seated
World Views so we've partly trans
transitioned into looking at how can we
employ these IDE ideologies that people
already have to encourage these more
integrated practices so changing the
language changing the conversation
around herbicides as the next technology
into maybe other kinds of technology or
the next technology and maybe it's
rotating those kinds of technology and
that's where the Techno optimism is
helping so I think that that's
absolutely a valid way of seeing it and
definitely some farmers were really
interested in things like the Harrington
seed Destructor which is like a
mechanical destruction in destruction of
seeds that's really taken off in
Australia um and even back in like 2014
2015 when I was doing these focus groups
people were already talking about that
and I've seen that grow in interest as
well so absolutely great
Point anything else I remember being in
IA several years ago yeah they were
promoting reparan
strips and it was really successful yeah
and as I recall the reason so much well
it prevents you know soil running into
the water and so but it improved
hunting I think they partnered with the
state to maybe stock Fe all it that you
know SE adoption a really high level so
I guess I'm just I was just sort of
thinking are there sort of secondary
incentives besides
Financial yeah that's a great question
in a in a way we're not thinking about
indirectly yeah that's a really good
question I know that um some of the work
being done in Iowa state is connected to
projects on modernarch butterfly
conservation um and how that's related
to pesticides and pesticide use and if
we can reduce pesticide use that might
help with monarch butterflies and it's
really interesting because it also it
kind of goes back to this idea of Good
Farming and what is a good farm and it's
like what's a pest and those kind of
things but people have actually been
increasingly proud of having more
butterflies on their farm and seeing
having more monarchs and more species of
butterflies on their Farm as an
indicator that they are good farmers and
so I think that conversation is starting
to shift right where there's like news
that some butterfly that hadn't been
seen in Iowa in like 50 years appeared
on this guy's farm and that guy was
really proud he was like yeah the
butterfli is on my farm like I must be
doing really well so I think another
thing with transitioning some of these
ideologies about how we use herbicides
and how we use different kinds of pest
resistance has to do with signals of
Good Farming and what people take good
farming to mean and does that mean a
completely clean field with absolutely
nothing in it and like no animals no
weeds no nothing or does it mean
supporting biodiversity in some ways and
how can we make that visible how can we
make it so it's not just yield
competitions right it's not just bushels
per acre but it's what does the
biodiversity on your farm look like and
can that be a valuable measure of being
a good farmer yeah I think that's a good
conversation to have I don't know if
it's really a defant hunting but has
potential yeah um so you mentioned an
example in Arkansas where there was a
successful program because of an
extension there who then retired are
there um you know any sort of like
trainings or like tools that you would
encourage um existing or future
extension Educators to start learning
about and using to try to be able to
reach these communities that seem to be
as you pointed out more individualized
and more polarized over time that's
tough um I would say as far as like
pesticide resistance and herbicide
resistance not really yet um Iowa State
the model for Community change that I
showed if you go on Iowa State
extensions website you can download that
for free and I think that's a great
starting point um that was developed by
rural sociologist Paul lassley who was
on this project before me before he
retired and it really outlines like how
communities change and how to talk to
communities but also what questions you
should be asking them um and so that's a
really useful tool but part of the issue
is that we don't have enough
sociologists working on this problem
something that happens to me a lot is I
get invited to do a ton of talks to
people in extension offices to weed
scientists to entomologists right and I
get more than I can possibly actually
attend and I'm one of the only people in
sociology doing this research and
increasingly rural sociology programs
are getting cut so there used to be one
in Washington state it was cut there
used to be one you know and they're
shifting and it's just not as supported
at universities as it used to be and I
think this is a real problem
um I think it's a problem in that we
need rural sociologists but I also think
it's an issue of educating people in
other fields about what the social
sciences are and how to use them and how
to collaborate effectively with social
scientists so that we can produce more
training materials like this and have
people that are social science smart
right no matter what field they're in so
that they can adopt those principles
into their own work so that's something
I'm really excited about pursuing into
the
future okay like anything else I don't
see any other hands up well
good thank you it was great talking to
youall I'll hang around I'm getting
lunch pretty soon but I'm here for any
more questions that you
have this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu